we're starting a new series tonight
unaddressed American problems where we
bring you the issues that are left
unresolved which leaves you at risk now
tonight rare and easily preventable
diseases are making a comeback there are
more measles cases in the u.s. in the
first three months of 2019 then there
were all of last year
and II think that's scary well there's a
mysterious disease right now causing
paralysis among young children
it's called acute flaccid mellitus and
it bears shocking similarities to polio
it's in 12 to 15 hours later she was put
on a ventilator and was a hundred
percent paralyzed from her shoulders
down it was difficult for us as parents
to watch my daughter going through so
much pain I'm gonna be able to do
anything about it it was almost like an
old man hunched over really just in pain
you know is dr. Anthony Fauci director
of the National Institute of Allergy and
Infectious Diseases dr. Fauci what is
costing let's start with measles and
we'll get to AFM what's going on with
the measles well the problem is that
parents are not vaccinating their
children in certain localized areas of
the country and when you get below a
certain critical level of percentage of
the community unvaccinated then when
someone comes into the community you
wind up getting an outbreak a typical
example is Rockland County in New York
and in New York City in the Hasidic
Jewish population someone went over to
Israel and they have a very low
vaccination rate among the Orthodox Jews
in Israel came back into the community
and because the children were not
vaccinated the umbrella of protection
and the community was lifted and you had
an outbreak and that's what's going on
in Rockland County right now
vaccinations still controversial in some
circles saying it's look you get too
many vaccines at one time you can have a
heightened risk of other problems
it's misinformation Laurie it really is
I mean if you look at the stat the
evidence-based facts vaccines are safe
the MMR the measles mumps rubella is a
safe vaccine and the measles vaccine is
one of the most effective vaccines we
have 97% let's talk about acute flaccid
myelitis I've been tracking this story
for some time this is terrifying these
are these are parents who have a healthy
child one moment
total paralysis on a ventilator the next
what is this well you know we're not a
hundred percent certain but the evidence
is mounting it's highly suggestive that
it is a post viral infection viral
syndrome and it's likely a virus that
we're tracking that's of a polio like
virus it isn't polio for sure it's not
polio but there's a class of viruses
called enterovirus and the
epidemiological occurrence of the
outbreaks of this virus coincides with
the outbreak of this acute effects if
you have if you have a respiratory
infection right are you more more
susceptible to getting infected by this
enterovirus what we believe is that the
virus enters through the respiratory
tract most children recover with no
problem at all but rarely a child gets a
post viral syndrome which is the acute
flaccid myelitis but you can't do a
vaccine for this until you identify the
specific virus exactly we need to prove
what virus is we think it's an
enterovirus d68 a specific kind of virus
but we don't know for sure
here are the symptoms of that sudden leg
or arm weakness difficulty moving the
eyes facial droop or weakness difficulty
swallowing slurred speech children
especially effectively crack well 90% of
them are children the average age is
four years old at recovery well they
don't necessarily recover completely in
fact most of the children have some sort
of residual paralysis or residual
weakness which is really very
unfortunate doctor dr. Fauci thank you
for these updates and we'll be tracking
this with you and come back soon good to
be with you Laura